hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comment today kicked off a
very important tournament of the year
the candidates tournament the winner of
this tournament will go on to face
Magnus Carlsen in November for the World
Championship now we're gonna take a
little bit of time just to go over who
qualified for the Candace tournament so
y'all know all the competitors because
it is such a high profile tournament the
first person is gonna be Vishy Anand he
qualified because he lost to Magnus
Carlsen in the 2014 World Championship
2015 we did not have a World
Championship so that makes this
tournament even more important because
Magnus Carlsen kind of been hanging out
there for two years waiting for someone
to battle him in November so Vichy Nam
because he lost he is the first
competitor in this tournament the next
two are gonna be the top two finishers
from the 2015 chess World Cup those are
certain attacking and Peter Svidler two
Russian grandmasters both very good
players excited to see them in this
tournament the next two are going to be
the top two finishers from the 2014-2015
chess Grand Prix we've been covering
that a series of tournaments over the
past two years and the top two finishers
were Fabiana Caruana and Nakamura two
American grandmasters so excited to see
a couple Americans in there the next two
are the highest rated players that play
in either the World Cup or the Grand
Prix those players are top lob and a
nice giri so excited to see those
players in here and then lastly there's
a wild card the nomination by the
organizers they go out and kind of
choose someone and they chose Levon
Aronian an extremely talented player
always does well in these type of
tournaments so those are the eight
players in this tournament it's a it's
about 20 days so from March 10th we kind
of had the inaugural kickoff with the
opening ceremonies today March 11th we
had around 1 this is going to go till
March 30th each player will play each of
their opponents twice they'll play one
is white and one is black so this will
be a fourteen round tournament there's
going to be a lot of chess played we're
gonna cover as much as possible so make
sure you check out both on YouTube the
channel and then on the website as well
the chess website comm we'll have some
extended coverage
on there as well but gonna be an
exciting tournaments with that we'll go
ahead and kick off what better way to
kick off around one then a vision on who
won this tournaments the previous year
in 2014 he won and went on to play
Magnus Carlsen ended up losing but he is
now back to revenge
you know his world championship and so
he's gonna be facing off against hope
off playing the black pieces so without
further ado we'll go ahead and get
started
this Chinon decided to start with pawn
to e4 something we don't see from him
very often d4 is almost always his go-to
play on the first move but pawn to e4
switching things up a little bit pani
593 knight c6 Bishop here to b5 getting
into the right Lopez and the knight to
f6 the Berlin defense and this is
defense we've just seen more and more
over the past year and a half to be
honest so no surprise here from total
have to go and play Knight here to f6
what was a little bit interesting is the
pawn here to d3 the anti berlin defense
if you will usually we're kind of seeing
that castle on the King side Knight
taking here on e4 and then pawn up here
to d4 we don't see that instead we see
just a pawn here to a d3 a bishop here
to c5 a castle on the King side pawn
here to d6 just solidifying the pawn
chain here and then pawn to c3 with
every intention of pushing forward here
with a pawn to d4 now see black castle
on the King side Knight here to d2 and
then black has a few options he could be
pretty passive and just kind of stay
back or it could be pretty aggressive it
so those two options are knight here to
e7 which is to kind of hang back right
here as you can see the Knights that
they've been coming here to d5 or f5
anytime soon so he has that option or
you can play Bishop here to e6 get his
life squared Bishop involved into the
action try to control the center of the
board a little bit more decides to go
and play knight in here to e7 not my
favorite move I definitely wish he had
played a little bit more aggressive and
now vichy homme plays pawn here to d4
and there's no real defense that black
has from this so we just kind of
to allow machine on to go ahead and take
this so pawn takes here pawn takes back
here on d4 and then Bishop back here on
b6 now this is a little bit different if
we were to see instead of not coming
back here to e7 Bishop here to e6
now machine on tries to try that pawn
here to d4 we see the capture here but
now after the Knight takes because the
Knights there are c6 attacking and
defending the square here on d4 why
can't really do anything because the
bishop is also defending this square as
well so just a very different approaches
how you know people have wants to play
in the Birdland defense but in the game
night here to e7 and them to see the
exchange on board and then Bishop back
here to b6 we work here to e1 just
centralizing defending this pawn here on
e4 is it pushes forward a [ __ ] period
of g4 just getting light squared bishop
involved into the game pawn here at age
4 kicking the bishop back and then pawn
to a4 and this is a novelty for white
this is something that we don't usually
see and so this kind of tells me that
vision on has prepared something special
for this tournament I don't always feel
like vision on is the best player at the
tournament he plays it but I always do
feel like he is the most prepared he's
the most methodical as how as far as how
he approaches his matches especially
depending on who his opponent is how
will go into preparation for that and so
pawn here to a4 I don't know if he
necessarily just looked at the Berlin
defense because he's been playing
against it so often especially in his
matches against Magnus Carlsen he just
saw maybe something specific when he was
white if he kind of played that pawn
here to d3 maybe got to this exact
position and he thought pawn here to a4
is not really seen but he thought it was
just an improvement over what's been out
there before all in all though pawn here
to a forward played it confidently so it
definitely seems like he he knew what he
was doing paneer to a6 forcing the
bishop at the bishop can really come to
a couple places Bishop here to e2 if he
wants to kind of stop that pin down on
the Knights on f3 we're Christians bring
it back here to f1 that's what he
decides to do a rook here to eh just
centralizing right here trying to
control the semi open file up on arrow
285 just forcing the bishop back here
287 and this does kind of lock this
Bishop out right now that this you can't
come here to b6 can't come here to c5
because these
so later on - Bob definitely wants to
kind of break open the center of the
board so his dark square Bishop can
control a little bit more of the game
Queen here to be three is you look at
both sides why it's really doing a good
job of being aggressive on board
controls the stare of the board you know
he has both of his bishops can easily
get involved into the action blacks kind
of cramped on board the light square
bishop over here isn't doing too much
it's it's pinning down a knight to
nothing right now both of these Knights
aren't really doing too much they can't
really get involved into the game
they're not really protecting their own
pawns in the center you know this Queen
right now is kind of blocked off this
Bishop here on the 87 is not doing too
much so mission on doing a good job you
know taupe Bluff kind of just hanging
back trying to try to find if he can
find an opening on board
so that's go and play Knight here to c6
attacking this pawn here on d4 so Vichy
Nadja cos this has good and push it
forward with pawn here it's the d5
foreseen the knight to come down here to
d4 almost and then the capture Bishop
ears who d4 and then the Queen takes
here on b7 this is one of those moves
they afterwards they ask fishing on
about and kind of said hey you know
taupe lob just gave you this pawn here
on b7 did you ever think about not
taking he said yeah you're not
considered Queen here to be for Bishop
ear to c5 potentially Queen urdhva to c4
Knight here to d7 he just didn't feel
like he liked his pieces he thought they
would be somewhat silly looking if he
didn't take here on a b7 so all in all
although he wasn't super happy about it
he said decided to go ahead and take
with his queen here on a b7 total of was
able to get compensation back for that
pond so he plays Knight here to d7 very
important move because it's a pseudo way
to protect this pawn here on a six right
now the bishop before that could have
just come here to a6 being protected by
the Queen right here but why can no
longer do that because of night here to
c5 so I might here to d7 a very
important move for taupe lob after
Knight here to d7 we see and I come up
here to d4 now that I come down here to
c5 Queen here to c6 and then night down
here to b3 and I think table
gave up some of his momentum that he had
he kind of has his opponents Queen stuck
up here or it's not really adding a lot
of value on board he has a pretty
aggressive attacks that he can do he has
two different options that I really like
the first one is just going all out
Bishop taking here on F - you know after
Vichy and on takes here on F - the Queen
can come down check we could see the
knight to come and board Knight to e4
check after the rook takes the Queen
captures here although he gave up a
minor piece he's a very strong attack on
board and towplow is gonna have a really
fun time just chasing busy and on all
over the board so that's one option
another option on board is just playing
pawn here to f6 then we have Bishop here
to e3 potentially we see an exchange on
board rook here to e7 getting ready for
the bishop to come back here to e8
attacking that Queen there's not a lot
of great squares for this Queen to go to
this Knights being protected by the pawn
if he wants to kind of escape this way
he's going along in those light square
diagonal squares where this bishop would
be attacking so all in all I really like
this attack took blob decided to go for
a different path and instead of either
of those he plays Knight here to be 3
and then rook here to be 1 and then he
plays that Knight takes here on c1 and
then the move that I just really don't
like I think even in in this position
it's fine but this dark square bishop
right now is not doing a whole lot I
think even just busting things open with
pawn here to f5 it's a way for toe Bluff
to be very aggressive where he knows his
opponent's does not have all his pieces
kind of unified right now and this kind
of breaks it open he can get his rook
very involved into the game putting a
lot of pressure on this efile he can
easily get his Queen involved into the
game if he wants to he still has this
bishop behind down on the F 2 square so
although I do think he made a big
mistake here
Knight taking here on c1 and then the
rook recaptures and then recover here to
b8 attacking this pawn right here
somewhat being held down that by the
knight but does need some added
protection since we have the bishop and
the rook both attacking that Square but
decides to go ahead and gobble up
- Oh first Queen here - a six now the
Queen's gonna come down here to H for
threatening mate right here so rook here
- see - both defending the square here
on F - and then also defending the
square here on B - which we talked about
so Bluff now comes down to e for capture
and material that's gonna come back here
to e3 Queen back here to d8 Queen
centralizing here - a c4 does have a
passed pawn now here on the a file
Bishop here - a g6 just trying to defend
some pieces bishop here to d3 wasn't
really doing too much on F once it does
need to make sure it gets involved into
the action a rook here to f4 and then
the Bishop takes here on g6 I think
mission on a definitely missed
opportunity here
you know tupelov had come to the
advantages and he kind of squandered it
a little bit as he kind of just gave up
his Knights gave up kind of his attack
here fishing on the other hand he kind
of has the advantage he could have
easily played pawn here to g3 and this
is really difficult for toe klav to deal
with the Queen could come down here to
g5 trying to hold on to that so the pawn
can't take here but just the Queen comes
up here capture here on c7 room could be
here on f8 just trying to hold down
material right here now after the
exchange this is gonna be good for
abyssion on in the game he decided to go
ahead and start with the bishop thinking
here on g6 which in the worst move I
just think there was a slight
improvement with pawn here to g3 first
after the pawn takes now we're gonna see
pawn here to g3 rook here to e4
attacking the Knights pawn up here 286
anytime you have a passed pawn you
should always be looking to push that
pawn and now it does have protection
from this Queen here on c4 Queen here
te8 trying just to hold control of the
start of the board this see file is very
important that is the open file in the
center so definitely want to have the
most powerful pieces Queens and rooks
involved into the action we're coming
here to e to just kind of
double-barreling here a bishop here to
b6 nice little outpost for the bishop
and also opening up the door for a
discovered attack on this Queen here on
at c4 so the Queen has to move still
wants to make sure it's holding down the
fort protecting this pawn here on a6
a now rook over here to a
so attacking this pawn with the rook
machine on does have the Queen here on
d3 now he plays King here to g2 and this
is another opportunity where I think
Vichy and on could have improved
you know pawn here to before with the
next move looking at pawn here to b5
would be very difficult for toe cloth to
deal with now not sure how long you kind
of analyze this hopefully he would have
seen it after route taking here on b4
which is kind of that the big threat
that why it has a playing paneer to be
for the night here to c2 is just deadly
but top off could just essentially
resign in this position attacking both
the rook and a discovered attack on the
Queen here on e 8 so the pond was
protected and then he could just push
forward with pawn here to b5 he didn't
really potentially see that he
definitely didn't play they play King
here to g2 now Queen coming down here to
a for putting more pressure on the pawn
here on a6 that pioneer to b3 not really
doing what it really needs to look here
to d4 tupelov says hey I'll go ahead and
trade off pieces if you want to fishing
on decides yeah let's go ahead and do
that night here to c4 and then Rua
captures here on a6 pawn up here to a5
Bishop here to add e4 work up here to e8
now the King over here to h7 if you
can't look out on board now that we have
five pawns to five pawns so while vision
on kind of had the advantage you can see
both sides they kind of go from the
advantage to you know back to equal and
then Bishan on kind of had almost a
really big advantage and then kind of
gave it back a little bit so definitely
has maybe that the more aggressive play
right now with both of the both of his
rooks
kind of teamed up right now attacking
his opponent's king side of the board
but I do think he missed an opportunity
to expand his lead that he already had
going into the endgame rook here to a c3
Knight here to d2 getting ready to play
Knight here to e4 and top life really
does not want the night to come here on
e4 it's just too hard to stop
this controls so much of the board over
here on the kingside it's almost a
certain play that you have to play pawn
here to f5 just kind of stopping that if
you can stop the knight from really
getting involved you can kind of
mitigate the risk of these rooks over
here and said that he decides to play
rook here to see to probably the biggest
blunder that he had in the game although
there may they're all making somewhat
small errors throughout Luke here to c2
is somewhat unacceptable Knight here to
e4 and there's no way to really stop it
now
it's got a great attack that he has pawn
ears f6 doesn't do anything for the
defense here pawn here to H for the rook
takes here on a5 and then so black is up
a material but why just has so much over
here on the King side of the board rook
here to f7 pawn here to g5 just trying
to stop the attack as much as possible
upon heir to h5 we're cover here - f2 I
would do see an exchange on board and
that's gonna be fun decided to go and
just come up here to h3 so now we have
two rooks versus a rook and a bishop and
then after the King takes who's he pawn
here to have five kind of a last effort
now and then rook to f5 and to blob in
this position it resigns on board so
congratulations to vision on the rest of
the games today all tied out and so we
have total of at the bottom with zero
points fishing on with one and everyone
else with a half a point so could not
have started any better for vision on
Saul I know he's got a ton of support
out there so congratulations to him
really excited to see kind of how it
plays out in this tournament there's a
lot of young chess players that I know a
lot of people myself included to be
honest are kind of hoping they can make
a splash you know having Magnus Carlsen
play someone else under 25 would be
pretty cool
but this you none you can ever count him
out he's very methodical and what he
does and starting out with a a victory
bodes very well for him and his
supporter so congratulations really
looking forward to the next three weeks
of chess hopefully you guys are excited
if you didn't know about
tournament get excited because there's
gonna be some awesome chess so thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you in
the next video